some of the story lines that came from
the newest episode of Untold about
Johnny Manziel
they're out of this world Johnny
Football claimed he watched zero film he
didn't watch a single film for his
entire NFL career but now it explains
why he went two for six as a starter and
only completed 57 of his passes in the
league Menzel's agent always had his
back though his agent attempted to fake
a family emergency to get Menzel out of
taking a drug test and when Johnny
partied way too hard with the ride
receivers the night before his workout
with the Cleveland Browns his agent
stepped in and caught the passes but
nonetheless even his agent was
absolutely flabbergasted when GM's
called him saying that Johnny logged
zero study hours on the iPad his rise to
stardom was one for the ages but when
you mentioned Johnny Football don't even
put him in film in the same sentence